[Music]
bookstores are portals to amazing
adventures and stories um brought right
to your fingertips literally i'm
self-educated i taught myself from books
by going to bookstores and so i'm so
passionate about reading because it can
change your life it teaches about
history geography humanity poetry love
just everything everything can be found
through reading but not everyone has
access
i was lucky when i was younger to be
able to go and purchase books or go to
the libraries and in manhattan there are
70 bookstores
to find your next great read
but head to the bronx and there's only
one
our next guest is a drew gooder
determined to change that one book at a
time please watch this
my name is latonya lavonne and i am from
the bronx i am the proud owner of bronx
bound books a bookstore on wheels right
now the bronx only has one brick and
mortar bookstore i believe a bookstore
should be a staple in every community
sometimes the kids in the bronx don't
have access to books until they are in
the school building my mission is to
make book ownership accessible and
affordable i purchased an old bus and
took out all the seats and flooring and
converted it into a beautiful bookstore
on wheels
we sell books at weekly farmer's markets
we visit schools
we go to shelters and we also host
various book drives there's such a huge
misconception about the people in the
bronx not wanting to read
i see young people all the time get
excited about reading
some kids come on and they can't believe
there's so many books others come on and
just sit down and just want to read they
think it's a genius idea for a bus to be
turned into a bookstore bronx phone
books feels like more than a dream come
true it's more than i could have ever
imagined it to be i wake up every day
thinking of new ways to improve how to
serve my community
and to make my dream even bigger
please
[Applause]
where did you forget this idea
i always wanted to own a bookstore
uh all my friends knew and i was just
having a conversation i was getting
ready to quit one of my jobs and my
friend vanessa said you know latonya you
have to just do the bookstore you keep
talking about this and i'm like well
the rents are so high in the bronx you
know gentrification is happening and
things are just really really changing
and i said i'm never going to be able to
afford a uh brick and mortar
so one day she just showed me a picture
of a book truck and that was all it took
for me to find the inspiration to do a
bookstore on wheels this is so genius
thank you
um
now this is personal for you will you
tell us why this is personal for you
well i grew up with my grandmother and
she was a teacher uh
not only did she teach the children in
the bronx
sometimes uh on any given saturday i
could come to my living room and i would
see her reading to her neighbors who
couldn't read so she would read lisa's
cable bills and just explained to them
why or when they needed to take their
medicine so seeing that showed me that
reading was just something that could
really change and save your life i see
the kids there
that's what you know
it does start there well we told the
publisher um
a kids company about all about you and
they're gonna give you five thousand
dollars worth of empowering educational
kids books wow
and then i'm gonna match it and give you
five thousand dollars just to enable
whatever you see fit and how to spend
that thank you so much
thank you so much i'm so in awe of what
you do and it is an honor to bring your
story to light to support you in our
tiny small way and just say keep going
because you are such a hero thank you
you are so amazing thank you latanya you
can learn more about bronx bound books
on the drewberrymore show.com where
you'll be featured on our website
[Music]
you